will the birds survive ozark will the
cartel or the fbi catch up with marty
first or will ruth kill just about
everyone what you need to know about
ozarks season 4 part 2 straight ahead
season 4 is the first season of ozark to
be split into two parts but fans fearing
an extended halftime hiatus needn't
worry too much instead of making us wait
for the back half of the final ozark
season netflix is gearing up to drop the
second set of episodes on april 29th a
mere three months after part 1 aired
ozark premiered its first season in july
2017 and returned for its sophomore
season in august of the next year the
third season arrived on march 27 2020.
considering ozark wrapped production on
season 4 back in october 2020 it was
always a possibility that we'd see an
accelerated release schedule but nobody
thought we'd be watching the end of
marty bird's journey as early as april
2022 netflix definitely deserves a big
pat on the back for this one
the second half of ozark season 4 is
expected to feature all of the regular
cast members from the first half with
the obvious exception of those who did
not make it out of the first seven
episodes alive all four members of the
bird family are expected to return
including marty played by jason bateman
wendy played by laura linney and the
couple's children charlotte and jonah
season four's seventh episode sanctified
saw the untimely deaths of wyatt
langmore and darlene snelangmore this
sadly leaves ruth langmore as one of the
last members of her clan left standing
julia garner has won praise for her
portrayal of ruth earning two
consecutive primetime emmy awards for
outstanding supporting actress in a
drama series we also think it's safe to
say that wyatt's younger brother three
will make an appearance at some point in
the final seven episodes it's unclear if
omar navarro or special agent maya
miller will reappear especially as
navarro was arrested by miller in the
mid-season finale
don't forget about me
but even if they don't return plenty of
emissaries of the fbi and the navarro
cartel remain additional characters we
expect to see back in the final seven
episodes of the series include javi
elizondro private investigator mel
saddam jim rattlesdorf and hannah clay
we also wouldn't be shocked to see
richard thomas return once more as
wendy's father nathan davis
the final seven episodes of ozark have a
lot hanging on the line for the bird
family while the fbi's deal with javi
would seem to be working for them at the
moment a closer inspection would
probably reveal that the deal is only
hanging on by a thread
and i really want to kill you you know
ruth has never been more distant from
marty than she is after javi murders
wyatt in the mid-season finale after she
finds wyatt and darlene's bodies ruth
holds marty at gunpoint and demands that
he tells her who killed them marty and
wendy refused to tell her but jonah
quickly outs his parents boss as a
murderer his name is javi alessandro
in the final scene of the episode ruth
promises to kill javi and screams
if you want to stop me you're gonna have
to
kill me
while ruth marty and wendy have tussled
in the past this seems like a definitive
breaking point for the two wendy and
marty are also going to have to deal
with jonah's continued rebelliousness
the young money launderer has previously
shown that he's more loyal to ruth than
his own parents something that seems to
bother wendy even more than marty we
also expect plenty of political
machinations by wendy along with the
family lawyer jim rattlesdorf since the
beginning of season 4 wendy has led the
bird foundation as a means of growing
the family's wealth power and influence
at some point ozark will also have to
catch up to the season 4 opening scene
which shows a disastrous car crash
involving all four members of the bird
family do you really think they're all
going to make it out alive
mel saddam played by adam rothenberg is
relentless yet he somehow manages to
stay calm cool and collected in the
process the former cop turned private
investigator will stop at nothing to
track down helen pierce as he was hired
by her estranged husband to discover her
whereabouts as a refresher helen was the
navarro cartel's attorney when omar
decided to have her killed allowing the
bird family to live all the same mel
continuously talks to anyone who will
hear him out as he presumably just needs
to know where helen is alive or dead
perhaps most intriguing of all is the
fact that mel has been talking to the
fbi though it would be ideal to see the
bird family make it out alive they have
dug themselves some pretty big holes
throughout ozark and it's seemingly only
a matter of time before they get caught
for one of their many crimes still fans
will have to wait and see if mel gets
his signature or whether he might play a
role in sinking the bird family
ruth is for better or worse on a rampage
she's lost virtually all of her family
members and wyatt's death is her
breaking point after all she threatens
the birds with a gun and viewers last
see her on the verge of seeking revenge
though javi is vicious ill-tempered and
seemingly thinks he's untouchable
audience members have come to discover
that you don't mess with ruth langmore
and a showdown between the two would be
pretty sweet assuming ruth comes out on
top if she did however actually pull off
her revenge chaos and madness would
likely ensue first and foremost killing
the head of the cartel is typically
frowned upon secondly the bird family
has a deal with the fbi which could be
jeopardized if hobby was to go down at
that point would the fbi have any reason
not to take marty and wendy down too
ruth may have been a trusted ally at one
point but marty and wendy likely don't
want their deal to collapse despite javi
being arguably the most savage enemy of
the bird family to date only time will
tell if ruth gets her revenge
this family's tensions aren't due to
everyday elements wendy and jonah aren't
at odds because wendy won't let jonah
say extend his curfew life-altering
mistakes have been made trust has been
destroyed and people have died i think
you have stockholm syndrome jonah has
rightfully been rebellious in season
four and he wants nothing to do with his
mother to boot since he believes she had
his uncle killed wendy didn't make
matters any better when she tried to
have jonah arrested but marty luckily
was able to put out that familial fire
surely jonah giving up javi's name to
ruth won't sit well with the family
although charlotte seems to be all in on
the family business this has only
further pushed jonah away wendy might be
more concerned with her political
ambitions right now but her family has
seemingly witnessed irreparable damage
one thing is for sure and that's that no
one is safe the car crash at the
beginning of season 4 looked fatal it's
largely speculation right now but it
would be a shame if the birds finally
reunited just for one of them to be
taken out by that crash
in a 2022 interview laura lenny was
asked if her character wendy still loved
marty and if she thought her family
would survive she told elle
yes she does love marty she does love
marty i think their relationship goes
through many different incarnations and
they are bound to each other and they're
sort of all they have they just have
each other really and i think wendy
feels that way lenny also revealed that
she relates to wendy in many ways
telling elle very much like wendy i
believe in that family as messed up as
they are as an actress i root for the
family as an actress i root for that
marriage whether it survives or not
whether the family stays together or not
i root for them though lenny's words
don't guarantee marty and wendy will
make it out alive we too are rooting for
the berg family
charlotte bird is apparently all in on
her family's business she's even
reconsidering going to college after all
why should she go when her family
already has a spot for her in their
company nonetheless we're all wondering
how her change of mind will play into
the final seven episodes of the series
though actress sophia who blitz who
plays charlotte doesn't give too much
away she has said something utterly
intriguing regarding the bird family's
ending in a 2022 interview with elle she
revealed it's a different experience for
me because it is my first major role
when we wrapped we wrapped our final
scene together as a family i won't say
what it was obviously the scene that we
filmed together was a scene as a family
that was my last scene it was wendy's
last scene it's still largely
speculative but the fact that the actors
filmed their final scene together could
mean that they were all still alive in
the end
it's not entirely marty's fault that his
family is working for the cartel but one
way or another he got them into this
mess for four seasons he has been trying
to make what he believes are the best
decisions to keep his family alive
needless to say it's been a rip-roaring
rollercoaster and we all want to know if
the series can stick the landing bateman
said in a 2020 indy wire interview
i do know where everything is going to
end i was interested in the big question
show runner chris mundy has the
opportunity to answer are they going to
get away with it or are they going to
pay a bill what does he want to message
to the audience about the consequences
of what the birds have done or lack
thereof viewers have similar questions
as it seems unlikely that this family
will receive a happily ever after
bateman also revealed we had some great
conversations about that and he's got
really good ideas about that
specifically what kind of happens at the
end of the last episode i know and it's
great if bateman believes the ending is
great then we'll take his word for it
the countdown to the end is on
in a 2022 interview with the hollywood
reporter showrunner chris mundy teased
what's to come in the final batch of
episodes explaining
i always want closure i don't want to
feel messed with i want to feel like
okay that was the end so hopefully
people will feel closure by the end
whether they like it or not i don't know
mundi also opened up about the show's
central relationship saying in terms of
tone we're going deeper into the family
and their bonds is family the ultimate
bond is friendship is marriage at what
point is it almost unhealthy to stay
even if you love somebody we're going to
delve into that with marty and wendy
hopefully the back half will still be
fun and exciting but also really
emotional for the birds and ruth
thankfully netflix has already released
a teaser trailer for ozark season 4 part
2 which mostly features a distressed
ruth on the verge of blowing everything
up it also touches on events that
plagued the birds and the landmarks in
the first half of season 4. ruth says in
the trailer my childhood traumas are not
like yours if this is any indication
ruth will likely seek vengeance for
everything that's happened to her
you see
i'm a cursed playing more
it remains to be seen what's in store
for marty and his family but it would be
a miracle if everyone makes it out alive
the reign of the birds and the langmores
is coming to a conclusion with the final
batch of ozark episodes on april 29th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]